this episode of real science is brought
to you by curiosity stream sign up today
at curiosity stream comm slash real
science and get free access to watch
nebula calm us humans are fleshy
vulnerable creatures all of our insides
and blood vessels protected by what is
our largest organ our skin it protects
us from the sun's rays it cushions blows
it lets us feel warmth and pleasure in
pain and unfortunately for our skin it
has a lot of work to do protecting us
because we certainly do our best to cut
burn slice scrape or otherwise abuse it
like Brian who helped me come up with
the idea for this video because he
sliced his thumb on a food processor
blade or me who fell off a scooter two
hours after I started writing the script
either because the universe was laughing
at me or it was just trying to give me
inspiration we've all done something
stupid like this though maybe not as
much as me but after the initial pain we
barely give it a second thought
as it heals up but what if the wound
doesn't heal like it's supposed to
if your body because of other health
issues is unable to heal there is only
so much our bodies can do and for people
with chronic wounds this is their
reality these wounds can get very nasty
and they often just don't heal
infections become a very serious risk
caring for these types of wounds also
puts the healthcare system under a huge
amount of strain coming up with better
wound treatments is one of Sciences
greatest modern-day tasks and there is
no easy answer but recent developments
in bio engineering and microbiology
indicate that one solution might involve
something unexpected electricity and in
particular electric bandages before we
investigate this new technology let's
first understand the normal wound
healing process there are many different
types of open wounds abrasion when your
skin rubs or scrapes against a rough or
hard surface like road rash lacerations
a deep cut or tearing of your skin like
getting cut with a knife or puncture a
small hole caused by a long pointy
object such as a needle nail or even a
bullet there are more than this too
there are so many ways to hurt yourself
but gross this aside
the way wounds heal like this is
absolutely amazing when you stop to
think about it the normal healing
process is often called the Cascade of
healing and is divided into four phases
hemostasis inflammation proliferative
and maturation hemostasis starts as soon
as you get injured the primary goal here
is to stop the bleeding within seconds
of the injury the body activates the
blood clotting system during this
process a type of blood cell called a
platelet starts to form a cluster the
clot also contains a protein called
fibrin which forms a net to hold the
clot in place after about three hours
the wound has sufficiently sealed itself
and enters the inflammation phase this
phase focuses on destroying any
pathogens that may have entered the
wound one of the most important immune
cells are a type of white blood cell
called macrophages that arrive to clear
debris and gulping it through a process
called phagocytosis this part of the
process is much more complicated than
this it could be a whole video by itself
once the wound is cleaned out the
proliferative phase begins where the
wound is filled and covered first
fibroblasts enter the wound and produce
collagen which makes up our connective
skin tissue then epithelial cells that
form the outermost part of our skin
cover the outside of the wound at this
point the wound is fully closed but the
tissue is not completely back to normal
during the maturation phase the new
tissue slowly gains strength and
improved flexibility collagen fibers
reorganize the tissue remodels and
matures and there is an overall increase
in tensile strength for most small
injuries and for most otherwise healthy
people this cascade of healing happens
without issue but if a wound is large or
chronic it's often not this easy chronic
wounds often happen in people with
diabetes for a number of reasons
elevated blood glucose damages tissue
reduces blood flow and can lead to
damaged nerves this then can cause a
loss of sensation especially in their
limbs and so patients don't feel
developing blisters or infections as
they happen these wounds can go
unnoticed and
get very bad and they are often
characterized by one of the deadliest
and most persistent types of infections
bacterial biofilms in general bacteria
have two life forms during growth and
proliferation in one form the bacteria
exists a single independent cells and
are usually the type found in acute
infections these can generally be
treated with antibiotics in the other
form the bacteria are organized into
tight clusters these clusters are known
as bacterial biofilm antibiotics that
can easily kill individual bacteria are
often useless against the same types of
cells when they form these dense
communities because the bacteria in the
biofilm protect themselves behind a
layer of sugar polymers and proteins
which the body's defenses and
antibiotics cannot always penetrate this
makes this type of infection very
persistent and very hard to kill
biofilms can also colonize medical
devices and implants such as catheters
prosthetic joints and heart valves 65%
of hospital-acquired infections are
caused by bacteria growing as biofilms
there are 1.7 million of these
infections annually in US hospitals
alone and nearly a hundred thousand
associated deaths biofilms are thought
to claim as many lives as cancer every
year for years scientists have come up
with different ways to fight biofilms
like inventing antimicrobial surfaces
for hospital devices or by attempting to
break down their protective coating but
these methods have their limitations so
this is why scientists are now battling
biofilms in a totally different way with
electricity killing bacteria with
electricity is surprisingly not a new
concept
in 1992 it was reported that a low
strength electric field helped to kill
biofilms that formed on stainless steel
this was a significant discovery but
scientists did not yet know why it
worked and therefore applying it
elsewhere was problematic some theorized
that the electricity disrupted the
bacteria's electrostatic bonding with
the surface or by damaging them through
electroporation but it wasn't until many
years later in 2015 that one possible
mechanism for this electric disruption
started to be revealed like with any
community of organisms these bacteria
that make up the biofilm have to
communicate with one another it was
thought for years that this
communication only happened chemically
but now scientists understand that they
can also send messages electrically
using potassium ions to propagate
electrical signals much like neurons do
this allows the bacteria to organize and
synchronize activities across large
expanses and recruit new bacteria
individuals to their community this was
a huge discovery and has big
implications for how biofilm infections
can be treated if communication is
disrupted bacteria can perhaps be
tricked into dispersing and made
vulnerable to antibiotics or the body's
defenses following this idea researchers
have developed wound dressings that use
an electric field to disrupt biofilm
infection called w e DS or Wireless
electro suitable devices one type of W e
D electro chemically self generates
around one volt of electricity upon
contact with body fluids such as wound
fluid or blood it uses a pattern of
silver and zinc embedded into the fabric
which when moistened
generates a weak electric field without
any external power supply the
electricity is not enough to hurt or
electrocute the patient but is enough to
disrupt the bacterial biofilm one study
showed that a silver zinc electrical
wound dressing along with an acellular
dermal matrix provided full healing
within six weeks on wounds that
conventional care had been unable to
close and up to two years this may be
because it disrupts bacterial
communication in part along with
generating superoxides toxic to the
bacteria in addition to its bacterial
fighting abilities electricity also
seems to help boost the human immune
response
researchers found that electric charges
recruit certain immune cells like
macrophages to the wound site which
further accelerates healing researchers
determined that the electric shocks were
stimulating angiogenesis which is the
growth of new blood vessels these new
blood vessels can then deliver more
blood flow and immune cells to the
damaged area allowing the wounds to heal
faster the research is now focused on
how to develop the technology to
stimulate the same response in
real-world clinical practice to make
what is essentially an electronic
band-aid some electro suitable devices
are already FDA approved and on the
market but there is still a lot of room
for this technology to be refined but
because electricity and wound healing
seems to be beneficial in many ways it
will continue to be studied rigorously
hopefully with more advanced electro
suta khals on the market soon wound
treatment is one of the biggest strains
on the healthcare system so new
technologies like electric bandages
could be one solution to help alleviate
that pressure how hospitals treat
patients largely relies on the
technology and supplies available to
them and the coordination of efforts of
many professionals even when times are
normal the logistics of this are
complicated but when extreme
circumstances arise the levels of
coordination needed to keep everyone
alive and well can feel insurmountable
as we currently witness the strain the
hospitals are facing due to this ongoing
pandemic we are starkly reminded of how
fragile it all is and how grateful we
all need to be to those who are working
tirelessly to keep shelves stocked
patients cared for and supplies flowing
to those who need them most if you want
to learn more about what is being done
to slow down this infectious disease you
can watch coronavirus combating the
outbreak on curiosity stream curiosity
stream is a streaming platform that has
thousands of high quality high budget
documentaries so if you're at home like
me looking for ways to occupy yourself
during this unprecedented era of self
isolation these documentaries are an
excellent way to both entertain
educate yourself and to make it even
better
curiosity stream has partnered with
nebula nebula is a place for us to
explore topics that might get
demonetised on YouTube and allows us to
create exciting original content real
engineering logistics of d-day series is
one nebula original that explores the
planning of the Allies successful
invasion of Normandy on d-day from
deciding on where to invade - how they
maintained their crucial supply lines
and there are many more originals like
working titles which is a collaborative
series where different YouTube creators
break down their favorite TV show intro
I just released an episode where I
analyze the intro for Westworld and
explore the show's themes about the
ethics of artificial intelligence and
because nebula has partnered with
curiosity stream if you sign up using
the link below you'll get access to not
just curiosity stream but nebula as well
for now just $14.99 a year and be
supporting a community of creators that
want to keep bringing you new and
exciting content during this weird weird
time